toujours des responsabilités quand même
si on considère
c'est pas parce que la police est
carapasonnée qui a des blackboards en
face c'est pas eux qui crient c'est
parce que j'ai dit j'ai dit aussi qu'il
y avait une montée des tensions par
rapport à la présence de la police
regardez hier la police qui confisque
les casseroles on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que c'est complètement
illégal donc on voyait des policiers
habillés comme des soldats qui
confisquent des casseroles où on est là
mais c'est pas la police qui est
responsable je vais vous dire qui est
responsable ce sont ceux qui ne prennent
pas les bonnes décisions politiques et
qui suscite des manifestations moi je
considère que bien présider un pays
c'est le maître à l'abri de toute
manifestation et donc on aurait ni
conflit entre des manifestants et de la
police ni des manifestants blessés
mutilés ni des policiers blessés on
n'aurait pas toute cette violence s'il a
par exemple très clairement la réforme a
été retirée on n'aurait pas toute cette
violence mais comment se fait-il qu'on
l'a subisse oui parce que les gens sont
attirés internationale regardez la
presse internationale c'est comment se
fait-il qu'un homme seul prenne en
otages sous un pays et de retirent pas
une réforme qui est refusée par la
quasi-totalité du peuple français ou
est-ce que c'est ça
et d'amour en politique et vous aussi
vous dénoncez les dérives de de la
politique actuelle et vous parlez de
frénésie de la politique et de
verticalité du pouvoir sans jamais
véritablement accusé Emmanuel Macron de
ces dérives là mais c'est bien ce que on
peut lire en creux c'est qu'il y a une
dérive dans cette verticalité dans cette
frénésie avec Emmanuel Macron au pouvoir
non je cible pas Emmanuel Macron parce
que je veux que ça soit une prise de
conscience ce livre voyez c'est pour
élever les consciences ce livre et des
verticalités ou des exercices solitaires
du poids il y en a eu avant avant lui
donc je veux pas personnaliser parce
qu'on penserait que c'est un pamphlet
c'est pas un pamphlet je fais c'est je
décortique 30 ans d'observation de
politique et je dis qu'on mérite
tellement mieux de ce qu'on a et que
c'est tellement simple quand même de
gérer et d'apaiser un pays faisait un
pays je le dis c'est comme une famille
si vous tapez sur la tête de vos enfants
en leur disant qu'ils sont nuls que
demain sera pire combien de fois on a
entendu cette phrase sans doute
d'ailleurs conseillée par les par McLin
C parce que c'est typiquement ce type de
manipulation des esprits si on dit un
enfant mais de masse rapide on va taper
sur la figure parce qu'on a décidé ça ah
c'est pas une bonne décision mais on
s'en fiche parce que on l'a dit donc on
va te l'imposer on va te taper dessus
jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce que tu
obéisses mais vous le cassez votre
enfant il sera incapable de grandir ni
de réussir à l'école mais d'avoir
l'année Emmanuel Macron des retraites
c'est des mots forts ça mais c'est la
réalité on est tous pris en total vous
ouvrez votre vous êtes contents quand
vous ouvrez votre télévision vous voyez
les images vous êtes content de voir ça
moi ça me fait souffrir j'ai donné 30
ans de ma vie politique que j'ai au
début de ce livre mais c'est une
souffrance de voir le pays dans cet état
alors
on parle on va voir quelques images
Madame Royal
[Musique]